I've been away for a few days and came
back to find that Prince William is
engaged to Kate Middleton and she has an
engagement ring and as soon as we see
something like that it's an excuse for
chemistry this ring which originally
belonged to Princess Diana Prince
William's mother and the ring consists
of a large sapphire blue stone
surrounded by diamonds and mounted on
white gold I think it comes from some
shop in London so you could buy one too
if you want it but chemically it's
really quite interesting sapphire is an
oxide of aluminium crystalline I've got
a largest lump here
the aluminium oxide itself is colourless
we use these as windows for our
high-pressure apparatus this lump here
doesn't look very big but it's worth
thousand pounds $1600 and it's quite
heavy we just use it because sapphire is
very strong we use it as a window so we
can look into high pressure vessels a
look at reaction mixtures here it's
colorless but what's really attractive
to people is natural sapphire this is
artificial made in the furnace natural
sapphire has metals dissolved in it and
depending on the metal so you get the
color and there's not very much metal
but it's one of the so called transition
metals which like iron chromium and so
on which are dissolved like in solution
and they have very bright color if you
dissolve chromium into aluminium oxide
you get a red colour
it's called Ruby and if you dissolve
iron or some other elements you get this
very nice blue or sometimes greenish
color so in the case of Kate's
engagement ring it is a piece of natural
sapphire that was mined somewhere I'm
sure outside the UK
and it's aluminum oxide with iron in it
you you can make synthetic sapphires but
then it's not so valuable you can get
large pieces of synthetic ruby they're
used in lasers the other part of Kate's
engagement ring are the diamonds and
diamonds a carbon special form of carbon
where each carbon atom is bonded to four
other carbons like this and the special
thing about diamond is that it is
absolutely clear like glass but what
makes it special is the way that it's
cut here's a piece of glass that has
been cut like a diamond and by cutting
it in this rather pointed shape then
when you look at it from the front it
Lintz it is terribly reflective you get
it's sparkling in the way that looks
really good I can't remember how many
diamonds she's got in her ring I think
it's 14 they're quite small ones but
they give a nice surround to the
Sapphire all these stones are mounted in
what is called white gold this is an
alloy mixture of gold with another metal
and depending how rich you are you can
choose different elements from group 8
of the periodic table the cheapest form
of white gold uses nickel which is near
the top of the group but then
increasingly expensively you can use
palladium or platinum I suspect in the
case of Kate Middleton's engagement ring
it's platinum because it makes it feel
heavier and chunkier because platinum is
so dense if you read the official
description it says the sapphire in the
middle is 12 carat and the gold
surrounding it is 18 carat now this is a
bit confusing because the carat in the
two contacts mean different things for
the Sapphire the caret represents the
weight it's a unit of weight that
used for measuring the weight of
gemstones the carat when it talks about
the gold is the proportion of gold in
the alloy so if something is 18 carat it
means it's 18 parts gold and six parts
another metal probably platinum could be
nickel now there's a really nice
experiment that I'd like to do with the
engagement ring though I doubt if Kate
will do it which is to heat it up and
plunge it into liquid oxygen the diamond
should burn but the gold and the
Sapphire should be left untouched have
you ever bought an engagement ring yet I
bought an engagement ring for my wife
many years ago hers was a is a diamond
ring but is quite no-one it was an
antique ring and the diamonds are cut in
a different way which achill rose
diamonds which is in the 18th century
the crystallography of diamond was not
as well understood as now so they don't
sparkle as much but I think they look
rather nice